[Music]
no yeah I mean let me just tell you what
Hanson College selected my senior year
they start like we really getting
Internet in here yeah like so one guy on
the whole dorm room had like a computer
we'd all like go around and like did
take 45 minutes to download like a boob
picture or something yeah
now it's instant gratification but even
gets to see all the boobs he wants
non-stop thanks thanks Internet
Al Gore thank you so much for giving us
access to these things and do you guys
remember like the first thing that you
guys actually did on the internet once
you finally got it out besides took a
picture I can tell you before the
Internet I went to my friend shin and
guthrie cells that he had I don't know
what kind computer was one of those like
old like and he gets some weird magazine
I had like all halves like weird stuff
to type in like oh let's say you type
all this stuff and they like enter and
and be like just like a picture of an
apple for like you don't like could see
we'd have to do what to make like a
weird like some kind of weird I don't
cuz I've got a computer picture
I'm obviously I'm not a computer guru
no no I'm Amish man I've got like you
know I bet I barely have a TV in my
house
no I'm Joe I'm super Amish you know yeah
but but uh
scoopa homie the first person that I
ever saw it I used dial-up internet or
that had it was Dave Thomas oh sure of
me so I was SCTV he's a technology guy
stuff he was an early adapter and I was
writing something with him I went into
his office in Santa Monica and he had
this he had dial-up internet like wow it
took forever you know I mean little
waiting for stuff to happen on the
screen I'm going yeah this is not
helpful at all and will never last but
thanks for your all right Dave enjoy
that yeah I give it I give it to like
your video phone yeah yeah I feel like
the first weird time I to think like
that I went to a guy was artistic
directors house for like we were doing a
show and he had like a you know some
kind of company meal there or something
we'd like get a load of this we'd like
go to his little computer room and he
had that game Myst missed my mule just
like walk around our island and play
with cubes or something like like what
is this there's like it is a walk around
and find I'm like just a computer game
but I like it look nice like I look real
like kind of like actual pictures yeah
but I was immediately bored
yeah it is it is kind of fun to live
vicariously through because you know we
both we hope do various types of shows
for various types of demographics and
audit yeah so so sometimes I'll be doing
like the day that we record paradise PD
I'll be doing some preschool show or PBS
KIDS show or something like that that's
like you know sharing is good you know
support your local library and then you
drive me to a paradise PD which is much
different voiceover because you go from
one to the other line it's nice a pair a
speedy like these guys don't shy away
from from any subject matter
everything's open season for
know they go there you know in the show
that is unafraid yeah baby
boost a pitcher he can even go to the
twin town offer like a paradox yes maybe
we might get a little bit a tweetable
the day beta plus big city is paradise
it's actually balls deep Burke what you
making it deep you moved yeah that's
right yeah if you do make it anywhere I
could test you like a like that triple
they leave me here it's up to your balls
deep bassy
[Music]
think about this you probably agree well
we both do this
the good thing about all the internet
that I like this
we're basically analog guys in a digital
world that is very job but like I have
one TV and fourteen record players in my
house yeah but you can go we can go on
you like every old VHS tape I was ever
saving I I now can feel like I can throw
it away because someone has put it up on
YouTube but you don't throw it I know
you know I do I know that's the product
really I'm gonna take it off yes they're
gonna they're gonna take that old by
individual off yeah I know a lot about
this I'm sort of the expert this will
show I mean I can tell you hands down
guaranteed there will be many crossovers
well really probably a whole cross
overseas by the way don't listen to
anything I say this across the show
there is some cross dressing I'm gonna
unequivocally say of course that will be
in season six a big crossover the whole
season to me crossover brickle people
feeding feeding Riggle PD own paradise
berry paradise yes that's correct
well I would say that there's almost not
a need for it because in my mind
brickleberry was a show that came to an
end too soon so paradise PD it's almost
like an alternate earth version of your
uncle Barry it's almost like the earth 2
version of brickleberry to me berkel
very I think you know the characters
have their single ashrams yeah and then
like chief Crawford lit his torch off
that one is now running pulse they're
all running to light the Olympic torch
yeah much of the cast is consistent Dane
is a new wonderful we're definitely it
is I had uncompromising photos of the
creator's so I had managed to get on Oh
because they were I'm saying they're
what we can't believe we've never
wondered dated before he is amazing we
are so you had bigger eyes yeah they
have to say that yeah they couldn't
avoid it a little closer stuff going on
but let's just say yeah
[Music]
the house I hate you
you and your gauntlet and then you turn
to dust then I hear the deaths other one